philippe pascot écrivain ex-adjoint de
manuel valls à la mairie d'evry
bonsoir philippe pascot merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur la france alors
vaquer parler avec nous de la question
de ces alliances de manière un petit peu
global c'est le jeu cynique de la
politique
non c'est le jeu pourri de la politique
c'est l'arrière cuisine des politiques
c'est des gens qui n'ont pas été capable
de s'affirmer qui donc essayé de se
regrouper plus ou moins en lâchant leurs
convictions parce que faut pas se faire
d'illusions quand on s'allie au 2e tour
au lhc conviction on travaille pour les
postes on travaille pas pour les
convictions alors justement ce n'est pas
de nature à augmenter encore plus la
défiance sein d'un électorat déjà voilà
pas toujours très en confiance avec la
classe politique on n'est plus dans le
cadre d'une défiance
on est dans le cadre d'une horreur je
dire les gens maintenant on en marre des
politicards en ont marre de ces
tambouille de ses salades de ces gens
qui passent leur temps à négocier des
postes plutôt que des convictions il n'y
a plus aucune conviction dans les
élections
la preuve regardez avec combien de
pourcentage ces gens là sont élus il ya
des endroits où ils sont élus avec moins
de 1 électeur sur dix - de un électeur
sur dix c'est plus de la démocratie on a
envie de demander dans ces cas là vous
étiez aussi responsables politiques
proches des manuels real de manuel valls
pourquoi ça continue ça veut dire quoi
que les politiques n'attendent pas le
message que va leur adresser l'électorat
savez on se trouve juste il faut tous
comme rivaux et ça rend sourd donc il
est évident que les gens comprennent pas
il s'est toujours les mêmes on retrouve
les mêmes quand vous voyez que il ya un
type comme copé qui s'est encore
présenté un mot et qui a été élu en plus
les gens là ne sont plus à l'écouté du
peuple
ces gens là sont dehors ils parlent tous
d'un nouveau monde d'une nouvelle
politique mais il présente les vieux
même vieux cheval de bataille alors que
faudrait il faire selon vous que ces
gens là arrête
il ya un type qui nous a dit en mai 2010
est qu'il allait moraliser la vie
politique que les gens n'allaient pas
pouvoir faire des carrières politiques
on constate au fur et à mesure des
élections c'est encore les mêmes qui se
présentent les mêmes qui nous vendent
leurs salades qui commence à être franc
la tht et les gens n'y croient plus les
gens ne vont plus voter regarder sur les
municipales les gens se sont tellement
abstenus qu' il ya plus que 0 carrément
0 1 % d'abstention dans les urnes
les gens en ont marre ils vont même pu
voter et c'est ce que veulent les
politiciens vous le savez fini parce que
c'est aussi dû à cette crise du
coronavirus en france était une erreur
vous faites partie de ceux qui pensent
que c'était une erreur de le maintenir
non seulement c'était une erreur mais
c'était une folie vous faites les
élections le dimanche et le lundi vous
confiner les gens vous n'avez pas
l'impression qu'il ya eu une petite
magouille là dedans
vous n'avez pas l'impression que quelque
part on est en train d'être complètement
dans distorsion vous avez le droit
d'être côte à côte dans les avions dans
les transports du rer c le matin pour
aller bosser et vous pouvez pas être à
moins d'un mètre cinquante dans les
restaurants et on va encore envoyer des
gens voter le 28 juin juste au moment où
ils partent en vacances et vous allez
voir que en septembre comme par hasard
on va re confiné à l'or lors du second
tour de la dernière élection
présidentielle
emmanuel macron et marine le pen l'appel
au vote a été un grand débat pour faire
barrage on le sait où et rennes certains
de gauche et de droite ont appelé à
voter mettront ça va être la même chose
pendant ces municipales comme c'est
souvent le cas
quelle est notre position là dessus
alors qu'on peut pas vous soupçonnés
d'être proches du rassemblement national
mais il n'y a pas un déni de démocratie
tour même à mais c'est paca d'élite
démocratie mais si ces gens là n'allumez
pas le feu ils seraient pas obligées de
l'éteindre
à chaque fois on nous faisant peur avec
le front national si ces gens-là été
bons dans les partis politiques qui le
représente
je vais vous dire les extrêmes
n'arriverait même pas au deuxième tour
parce que l'ensemble des gens qui votent
les extrêmes c'est pas des extrémistes
c'est des gens qui en ont marre qu'ils
ne sont
reconnaissent plus dans aucun parti
politique et il se réfugie dans une
autre famille un peu plus un peu plus
extrémistes si ils étaient n'y ait pas
s'il a lui mais pas les incendies il
serait pas obligé de les éteindre
catastrophe mais en plus il faut que
vous sachiez que pour la plupart des
politiques ça les arrange que le front
national soit au deuxième tour ça les
arrange que les extrêmes soit au
deuxième tour parce que celui qui arrive
au deuxième tour il est aujourd'hui
quasiment sûre d'être élu mais faites
attention le peuple et pas si con ça
veut dire que beaucoup jouant le jeu non
pas du front national mais du
rassemblement national notamment à
commencer par souvent on l'accuse de
cela en tout cas le président de la
république lui-même mais ils en jouent
ils en abusent ils en abusent
parce que c'est pas un type qui vote qui
veut voter pour qui fit voter les gens
pour les convictions comme ça c'est des
gens qui travaillent qui magouille qui
font de la cuisine et aurier électorale
uniquement pour avoir des postes parce
que la soupe est bonne et qui veulent
garder la soupe
c'était différent quand vous étiez vous
aux affaires aux côtés de manuel valls
oui j'suis pas que manuel valls à manu
mais je t'appelle dark vador maintenant
je suis là sans quelle raison pourquoi
parce qu'il est qu'il est passé de
l'autre côté du miroir et je suis la
seule personne qui me soient battues
physiquement deux fois avec lui mais moi
j'ai connu la politique en 25 ans avec
moi des gens qui étaient peut-être entre
guillemets ou si des ripoux mais au
moins il avait un peu de classe
aujourd'hui non seulement c'est des
ripoux mais c'est des gens qu'on pût de
classe je vais vous dire une chose en
politique aujourd'hui
le mensonge est devenu la règle et la
vérité devenu l'exception c'est avec ça
que ces gens là ils nous regardent dans
les yeux et nous disent regardez je suis
bon regarder alors qu'ils ont rien fait
il ose dire qu'ils vont faire mieux
c'est une honte et c'est pour ça que les
gens ne vont plus voter et c'est pour ça
que les gens se détournent de la
politique mais comme c'est eux qui se
partagent le gâteau entre eux parce que
regarder sur les élections municipales
dans tous les endroits où il ya des
cadors dans tous les endroits où il ya
des responsables politiques de premier
plan
il n'y a jamais un homme politique de
premier plan qui se présente contre lui
ou contre elle ils se sont partagé le
gâteau ces braves gens et ils se
partagent les
gâteaux sur toute la france et est-ce
qu'il ya un seul parti politique
aujourd'hui qu'à dénoncer les élections
du 28 juin
aucun ils sont tous d'accord pour qu'on
le fasse parce que ça les arrange parce
qu'ils ont bien compris que moi y'a des
gens qui votent plus ils sont sûrs
d'être élu dans certains endroits et ils
ont fait leurs comptes
merci en tout cas un philippe pascot
d'avoir été avec nous nous avoir voilà
apportez votre coup de colère ce soir
sur rtl france merci à vous